bill Rabinowitz is the beat writer for
The Columbus Dispatch covering the
Buckeyes and bill kind enough to join us
this morning when did you first hear
about this story bill well it was
actually a very kind of minor saying
back maybe a couple weeks ago when it
pops off kind of out of nowhere that
Zach Smith was going to be a period
course and like in 15 minutes from then
on this kind of very minor obscure
charge of criminal trespass and didn't
think much of it not okay this is a very
minor thing and then talk to his
attorney that day and then it just kind
of blew up from there so a couple weeks
it's it's just kind of amazing how
quickly this has developed what do you
know about Zach Smith with this
situation with his ex-wife and and how
many incidents were there at Ohio State
and Ohio State you know we didn't know
anything until just recently you know
there was no you know we knew that Zach
Smith and his wife had had divorced a
couple years ago didn't know the details
of that it was clear now and obviously
in my reporting others it was it was a
pretty volatile marriage and then and
ended honestly in divorce we didn't know
any anything about potential domestic
abuse at all until until recently what
did you make of Urban Meyer's denial
yesterday that the first II heard of
this was Wednesday night yeah actually
the big 10 meetings last week or big 10
meet is last week yeah when he came out
and said that that was a pretty kind of
a line in the sand and I was a little
surprised that he was so definitive that
he would say yes I knew about you know
something in 2009 when they were both in
Florida but I didn't know anything about
2015 until I asked our people to check
it late last night
and that was like okay this is what he's
saying he he you know this is when he
knew it and what he knew it and that's
probably the big issue right now for him
is is if in fact he did know it and
Courtney Smith apparently told Shelley
Meyer yes and Shelley Meyer and Urban
Meyer of course are very close and and
did Shelley Mayer then tell her Meyer
did Urban Meyer forget them I mean
they're that's for the investigation to
decide but that's really the question
and an Urban Meyer probably could have
hedged a little bit last week in Chicago
and Holly but on safer ground is this a
fireable offense yeah I don't want to
make that judgment I'm not I'm not the
judge or jury it's not for me to say I
think that he has certainly put himself
in jeopardy that nobody would have
foreseen even yesterday honestly at this
time and Paul Brown is nolasco highest a
coach to leave on his own terms and 1942
I think we what he Hayes Jim Tressel
Earle Bruce I mean everybody has been
fired and I really thought and most
people did that Urban Meyer is going to
be able to leave on his own terms
because of a success here because he had
run a clean program though no hint of
n-c-double-a violations it was rolling
and now everything is up in the air is
there any connection correlation with
Jim Tressel with how he got fired see I
thought about was these are kind of
errors of omission I mean Jim Tressel
and one of his big the one thing he
really couldn't get past was when he
said what he signed off on that
n-c-double-a form saying he didn't know
of any and some play violations when
clearly you got emails about it with
herb admirer it's you know what did he
know did what did he do if he in fact
knew about something and why would he
say he didn't know when evidence shows
that he that at least there's a strong
possibility that he would have been told
so yeah it's almost like more errors of
omission and Commission so what's the
plan for the program with practice
opening up on Friday yeah it's gonna be
kind of crazy I mean in 2011 which is my
first year on the beat
Luke sickle had had taken over under
kind of similar circumstances but that
was in late May and this is literally
tomorrow is the start of training camp I
was a little surprised that that Ryan
day was the one appointed acting coach
instead of somebody who's experienced as
a head coach like like Greg Schiano or
even Kevin also new coach tonight ocean
Indiana that's a question we have not
gotten answered why Ryan day but it's
gonna be crazy
I mean you're breaking it a new
quarterback and Dwight Haskins you've
got questions you got to answer on both
sides of the ball now it's Ohio State
they're considered to be a favorite to
make the college football playoffs again
it's it's the program is bigger than one
man but nobody wants to see unless
you're a Michigan stick and I said eyes
they going into training camp with this
kind of turmoil and uncertainty
he's bill Rabinowitz he covers the
Buckeyes he's the beat writer for The
Columbus Post Dispatch joining us Dan
Patrick show but you start to look at
this program and and we were talking 15
minutes ago
where Paulie my producers said you know
what does does the Ohio State try to
wrap this up just to kind of pacify you
know placate perception-wise I said no
that's not how I Oh state works Ohio
State is in its own vacuum but they only
care about Ohio State and those fans so
I don't I don't see them doing something
just to placate the rest of the country
your thoughts on that
yeah I agree I mean there's a process
and unfortunate for Iowa State they're
going through a similar process now
because they've had their scandal with
the the wrestling doctor who you know
it's a bit of a version of the Michigan
State very nasty story not quite to that
extent but it's a doctor who was accused
of abusing or with wrestlers and other
athletes at Ohio State so they've
they've hired a firm to to investigate
that I don't know who they're gonna hire
to investigate the Urban Meyer matter
and this this whole thing but yeah Ohio
State's going to do what Ohio State's
going to do in the time that they feel
like they need to do I don't think
they're gonna feel outside pressure to
rush to a conclusion I just I just think
that that's the way that the last eight
handles things
if I talked to you in a month is Urban
Meyer the head coach at Ohio State
I've always afraid of these questions
you know that's where I kind of got to
go back to that I'm not the judge a jury
I you know I I don't think of my place
as the beat writer to say I will say
this though that I he is any position
that even you know twenty-five hours ago
I would never have thought he would be
in and the idea the rubber buyer is is
very potentially looking at at a forced
exit that not being able to leave on his
own terms is pretty shocking I'm not
going to say what the percentages are of
that happening but the fact that it's
happening that it is a real possibility
at all is just kind of shocking I know
you got a busy day we appreciate the
time bill thank you very much thank you
it's a bill rabinowitz covering the
Buckeyes for Columbus Dispatch yeah you
know what
as a writer beat writer you're probably
saying alright hey I got a profile
coming out you know we got a new
quarterback or just how good this team
is and having lived in Ohio and grown up
on Ohio State football that's what that
state's all about it starts with the
Ohio State Buckeyes and the fact that
you could 24 hours ago Urban Meyer is
getting ready to coach and practice
opens Friday and then here we are paid
administrative leave and the possibility
of losing his job there amazing happens
quickly for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]